la valeur de ces objets c'est
l'ancienneté des bijoux des tableaux ou
encore des lettres anciennes scrutés par
l'oeil avisé de commissaire priseur
plusieurs fois dans l'année un hôtel des
ventes aux enchères parisien délocalise
son activité à versailles le temps d'une
journée pour venir à la rencontre des
particuliers soit il souhaite seulement
une estimation pour savoir combien vaut
un objet pour une raison d'assurance ou
les partages soi et souhaite lui confier
à vendre et dans ces cas-là il le laisse
essayer en dépôt et nous on le vendra à
paris comme estimations j'aurais
tendance à mettre dans les 800 à 1200
qui est une estimation raisonnable
je trouve que c'est très bien parce que
là beaucoup de jolies choses à
versailles ça et vidal et à paris on a
estimation qui est certainement fiable
plus qu'une estimation cette opération
également pour but d'en apprendre plus
sur les objets apporté des trésors de
famille qui remonte pour certains au
milieu du 19e siècle
j'ai un livre très anciens l'a donc
raconter un petit peu son histoire et et
comme il est à moitié manuscrit il est
relié à moitié manuscrits donc elle m'a
un petit peu expliquer à quoi ça
correspond des autographes aussi des
autographes du second empire
chaque objet précieux il suffit qu'il
soit rare quelle que soit la matière
dans laquelle il est fait donc un
tableau peut être aussi précieux qu'elle
ya mis les objets collectés lors de
cette journée d' expertise seront mises
en vente en mars
d'autres opérations de ce type auront
lieu dans les prochains mois à
versailles